welcome to today's sponsored episode of
machine learning Street Talk I'm your
host Tim scarf and today we explore one
of the most radical frontiers of
technology and Humanity the digitization
of the human mind
my guest is Dimitri Shapiro CEO of uai a
company building tools to understand the
mind
Dimitri believes that digitizing our
mental experiences and insights could
unlock tremendous benefits but mapping
the human psyche also raises deep
questions
in this conversation we grapple with
mine digitization's possibilities and
perils and how it will transform
learning relationships even our sense of
identity what risks will we Face by
rendering our inner lives as data and
can we develop this technology
responsibly while upholding human
dignity
the interplay of topics we discuss is
complex but compelling we explore how
digitizing the mind could enhance
empathy and connection between people
yet also threaten privacy
it may improve education and mental
health but risks exacerbating inequality
if misapplied
most profoundly mind digitization forces
us to ask what it means to be human in
an age where technology mediates our
understanding of ourselves and others
will we risk losing something intangible
as we render the psyche in bits and
algorithms or gain a new means of
flourishing by optimizing our cognition
and relationships
there are no easy answers but Dimitri
offers a vision balanced by hard
thinking about the challenges ahead his
perspective provides a glimpse into a
future that can unsettle us or fulfill
our hopes what if you had a digital
assistant which truly knew you one which
understands how you think what you know
your strengths weaknesses aptitudes
interests and values an AI that can
enhance your life in profound Ways by
augmenting your weaknesses amplifying
your strengths and connecting you with
like-minded people
that is the vision of uai uai is an app
which allows you to build a personalized
AI assistant by engaging with
interactive prompts and questions as you
share details about yourself uai builds
a rich multi-dimensional model of your
mind it captures not just what you do
but how you think
with uai you get a personalized feed of
prompts tailored to you answer questions
about your preferences beliefs
experiences and uai learns what makes
you you
the more you engage the smarter it gets
and soon uai insights emerge revealing
surprising connections and patterns in
how you think
it gives you thoughtful nuanced
responses based on a deep understanding
of you
uai believes that by digitizing our
minds we can unlock human potential we
can gain insight into ourselves deeper
relationships with others and AI
assistance which truly Empower us now
uai is an ambitious vision for how AI
can enhance what makes us human
our minds
by sharing and connecting with our inner
worlds uai believe that together we can
build that future our minds contain
infinite potential and uai say that
their technology helps unlock it
today is a big day uai just released
mind Studio mind studio is an app that
allows anyone to create their own AI
experience with an easy to use visual
interface you design interactive prompts
and questions to gain context into how
people think
in mind Studio start by crafting
personalized prompts and questions to
map how a person thinks choose from a
range of prompt types from open-ended
questions to images to ratings
select the prompts which provide the
most insight into your audience organize
the prompts into a feed reorder or
delete them at any time see what data
each prompt collects and Export it for
analysis the more people engage with
your prompts the more mind Studio learns
insights emerge showing how different
people connect ideas or where their
thinking aligns and differs next give
your AI instructions for what you want
it to do in the AI composer set
parameters like temperature to adjust
how creative or predictable its
responses are choose which model Powers
your AI mind Studio supports chat GPT
Claude and more
your AI can also have automated
responses which trigger based on user
input once built share your AI for free
or even charge for Access make it public
so others can use and remix it or keep
it private see how people interact with
your AI and refine it over time
mine Studio opens up AI to all anyone
can create personalized AI experiences
to gain Insight connect with others and
share ideas mind Studio believes that AI
should enhance human thinking not
compete with it
what will you create with the power of
Mind Studio a new way to understand
yourself or others an AI to share ideas
that matters to you the possibilities of
Mind Studio are as endless as the human
mind now we're going to have a session
on the mlsd Discord with the uai folks
on Thursday the 13th of July at 9 00 am
PST you can go into the mlst Discord now
and sign up for the events and they're
extremely interested in having a
discussion with the wider Community to
get a feel for where they should take
the product and also enlisting help
figuring out how to improve their mind
Studio templates
we started by asking Dimitri you know
why he believes the mind can and should
be digitized and from there we explored
mind digitization's potential impacts
and implications the risks rewards and
deepest questions this radical Frontier
presents I hope you'll join us for this
glimpse into the future of human
progress and possibility in an age of
digitized minds and yeah let's let the
conversation commence
cheers okay folks welcome back to mlst
today we have Dimitri Shapiro he is the
CEO of you AI now prior to founding uai
with the CTO Sean Phelan Dimitri worked
on Google's social machine learning team
as a group product leader and he was
also the CTO at Myspace now Dimitri's
Focus today is going to be uai and it's
all about building a digital mind which
can kind of index everything that you
know and he's coming out of stealth mode
which is pretty cool so anyway
um over to you Dimitri why would you
want to index your mind
uh well first of all thanks so much for
having me on really excited to chat with
you
well when we take things that didn't
used to be digitized and digitizen we
start to be able to do things that we
couldn't do before
and so I periodically give an example of
I remember the days when you know if you
wanted to get somewhere in a car you
have to have a paper map in your car and
then sort of pull over and look up
the address you were looking for and
sort of map it out manually and then
Google by digitizing roads
you know was able to create Google Maps
and now we got you know not only sort of
turn-by-turn directions so we don't have
to pull over we can just keep driving
but we get like all kinds of other
things we get traffic rerouting we get
this business is is going to be closed
when you get there like so all of these
sort of new capabilities that seem like
super powers and all of that comes
because things are digitized or before
we digitized you know books you have to
like drive to the library and look up
Dewey Decimal System and then you sort
of find the dead end but as soon as we
digitize things we got hyperlinking and
we got search and we've got all these
capabilities and so the Dynamics of
digital are radically different than
dynamics of physical or biological and
so it stands to reason that if we can
you know digitize things whatever they
are we get to get all kinds of potential
superpowers
and uh with the human mind I think uh
it's clear to us that
um
our minds are full of data we don't
think of it as data in fact I think most
of us find that there are some mental
constructs that we are aware of there
are some beliefs biases uh preferences
you know sort of various types of of
things that we're consciously aware of
uh some things obviously that we are not
aware of but we feel somehow these
things sort of drive us and sometimes
make us do things that we sort of you
know scratch our heads and say I wonder
how I can sort of get rid of that habit
for some reason I'm sort of drawn to do
it I know it's not good for me but like
here I am doing that again uh and and so
all of this feels like data and if we
could take that data and digitize it
then we should be able to do all kinds
of amazing things with it
wonderful so just to give some context I
mean we would have spoken about this in
the intro but you're building this
incredible platform which learns about
the people that use it and behind the
scenes you're using large language
models and you're kind of transforming
this personalization process into a form
of prompting so that the user gets
relevant results and that can be
platformatized and productionized in a
bunch of whole different ways so we can
we'll talk through the whole process
here but
um I guess we should start with the
beginning so I played with your app and
it was a little bit like a tick tock
interface and you would flash through
all of these cards and it would ask you
lots of very incisive questions so that
you could learn more about me so maybe
we should start with the UI itself
because I think that's quite instructive
it's almost like there's an element of
gamification in there it's very engaging
and the questions are very relevant how
did you come up with that
so we are not intentionally trying to
make it feel like it's gamified although
I could see how somebody could get that
from it
um I think it's clear if we look at what
humans like to do
you know with with digital with their
phone is this sort of action of
scrolling through feeds whether it's
tick tock or Instagram or Facebook or
Twitter or like we like scrolling this
is sort of the natural action and and
this feels I think for many people
um
kind of like calming kind of like a
fidget spinner
and and so I think it makes us feel good
it's comfort food we reach for it when
we're bored or lonely it feels good to
scroll so I you know it's really clear
to us as we were you know thinking about
building this interface and by the way
we're still just enough so we're very
early on with all of this but but it
seems clear that that's probably the the
right default interface to have
to make it sort of plausible for humans
to be able to spend
um
potentially a lot of time you know over
their lifetime sort of going through and
engaging with this machine and and uh
these uh
you know full viewport sort of scroll
interfaces feel like the right way to go
although we sort of considered other
types of interfaces as well but but
that's the reason for it is like that's
that's what we like to do and that feels
natural and I think that feels almost
like second nature now people don't have
to think about it they know how to you
know scroll up and down
okay okay so there's there's a whole
bunch of questions that I was asked
ranging from what kind of food do I like
versus you know where do I live and how
old I am and so on and these get
translated presumably into language
model prompts that will make the virtual
assistant far more relevant and at the
moment is it a static list of questions
or is it in somehow you know is it
somehow dynamically generated
yeah so at this moment the list of
questions is created by humans
using what we call Prompt templates we
call these questions prompts
and so you prompt an llm but uai prompts
you and it prompts you with these
interactive Again full screen
um full stack JavaScript
experiences they can be simple multiple
choice questions or open answer
questions but they can be in fact games
or anything else multimedia that can be
presented to a user in order to sort of
solicit a signal
out of their reaction and and then be
able to collect this signal and do
something with it and that signal might
be something that is then routed to an
llm or it might be something that has
nothing to do with sort of interfacing
with large language models but simply to
digitize our minds and be able to
compare ourselves to other people and be
able to find anomalies and sort of all
of these things and so we look at all of
these prompts by the way today we have
over 40 different prompt templates that
can be configured by humans today to
create these prompts you saw sort of a
narrow set of those which are the ones
that we have running in Alpha right now
but um soon you will see you know quite
a diverse set of prompts that are
presented to people so that's sort of
the prompt types there's also the prompt
content sort of the the topics of the
prompts again today those are chosen by
humans and I'm glad that you found it
sort of compelling and interesting but
but they are sort of almost randomly
chosen by humans so here's an idea I'll
have it sort of without much thought
about what to present to to users over
time we certainly expect a large portion
of these if not all of them to be
machine generated and and obviously
personalized and so I think people will
go through potentially quite different
paths as they digitize their minds
depending on who they are and how they
start and sort of like each next prompt
is going to be influenced by prior
prompts that that you've engaged with
today the system is is dumb it just
gives sort of uh everyone an onboarding
set of prompts that are
sequenced in a explicit way and then
sort of randomly pulls from the Corpus
of prompts that are available for uh the
rest of the experience right now
yeah yeah I guess um the way I think
about it is the the human mind is
exponentially complicated and it's
really really difficult to index a human
mind and the way I visualize it is kind
of like you have this High dimensional
euclidean space and every time you ask
them a question you're placing a
hyperplane in that space and you're
placing another one and you're placing
another one and you're zeroing in on who
that person is and at the moment the
hyperplanes have been chosen in a
principled way and we can talk about
what those principles are but they're in
a way which is quite uniform and
everyone's being asked the same
questions and then over time perhaps the
um the process can become more Dynamic
so in response to interactions in the
downstream applications we could be kind
of placing new hyper planes it's a bit
like a search process talk refining and
refining yeah really we look at a sort
of disambiguation
never-ending disambiguation of of
um
what might be sort of inside of humans
and by the way obviously we are all
changing all the time as well so this is
a process one that you it's it's not
something you do you don't digitize your
mind when you stop if you choose to do
this this is a behavior that you engage
with potentially for the rest of your
life theoretically and as you change
this thing should be able to detect
that you're changing through sort of
reprompting and prompting from different
angles and and uh
you know human language prompting for
example if I was just using language to
be able to to prompt people is is quite
crude and limited right uh and sort of
low resolution potentially but as you
get these multimodal prompts and again
as the system gets smarter today it's
completely done uh but in the Futures it
gets smart then it should be able to
be quite sophisticated in in being able
to figure out changes in in your mental
models uh things that you might feel you
are accurately conveying to it but you
know we often sort of don't really know
ourselves for certain things like
sometimes our friends and family tell us
things about ourselves that
after some thinking we're like oh
they're actually right but that's not
the way I would have described myself
and so we
unintentionally you know potentially
might lie to this system and its job is
going to be to be able to to find that
disambiguated sort of proposed uh new
ideas Etc
yeah it's quite interesting on
psychological questionnaires they quite
often ask you the same question in
different ways and people have an intern
or an external profile and similarly we
are different people in different
situations and the problem is from a
machine learning point of view that
that's noise isn't it so um I guess do
you represent that with a complex model
that could behave differently depending
on the situation
probably again at this moment we are
focused for a tiny team we're focused on
sort of the first part of this is how do
you get humans to engage with a feed of
these prompts sort of experimenting with
different types of prompts uh and and
sort of starting to think about how do
we
um
take them from being again sort of
randomly chosen by our small team of of
people and and for testing purposes and
sort of allowing them to be a bit
smarter and so the next step we're
taking uh that you will be the first one
to to hear about outside the company is
uh allowing
um regular users to create collections
of prompts
and then to be able to take those
collections of prompts and and allow
other users to go through them for the
purpose of sort of two things one is to
be able to calculate some insights about
the group of people that engaged with
these prompts
just with some standard sort of you know
graph analysis at this moment not really
machine learning so like clustering
anomaly detection things like that and
then secondarily to be able to uh take
the output of Engagement of these
prompts that output some labels
concatenate them and and Route them as
context with a preamble intellilamps
and so this one app's called context
which allows you to go through a series
of prompts and again it might be about
your preferences in air travel
and as you've gone through that
collection of prompts we can now take
all of that data and present it to you
know chat gbt or Claude which are really
the two apis that we have access to
today and allow you to have a
conversation with them with this thing
being injected sort of per session
yeah that makes sense I guess um the way
I'm thinking about it is you're mixing
together different levels of specificity
So In traditional psychology you know
there's things like Myers-Briggs where
they were trying to project you onto all
of these different axes of personality
but there's also very specific
information like I prefer United
Airlines and I guess you the beauty of
language models is you can just kind of
dump all of that information into a
prompt and it will make sense of it
depending on how you're calling it which
is really interesting by the way I mean
everyone's talking about this um I
watched an episode an episode of Lex
Friedman interviewing uh Zuck the other
day and he was saying that they're
building virtual assistants and it's
really useful for Content creators for
example because they need to replicate
themselves they need to scale up their
interactions with their fans and you
know if I'm if I'm unwell and I you know
I'm off from work I need to be able to
send emails and still communicate with
people in the workforce so I think this
whole concept of a virtual assistant is
really going to take off
I think that's cleared to all of us as
well
and and while we
think that's really exciting like all of
the work that's being done in Virtual
assistants including bios we we kind of
see the work we're doing as being much
more fundamental than that where
certainly this data that you're
collecting you know sort of teasing out
of your own mind is valuable to be able
to train an assistant to do all kinds of
uh things
um but at the same time there's lots of
other benefits for humans to digitize
Minds like today when we meet someone
we have some small talk and we sort of
try to figure out who they are what
they're about and and over time can get
to know a person you know quite well
obviously our friends and family that
we've grown up with and but periodically
I don't know if you've experienced this
I've experienced this a number of times
in my life where some of my closest
friends or family will say something and
I'm like
how did I sort of not know this about
you like after 40 years of being
together how is this something that sort
of slipped by well that totally makes
sense because there's sort of a limited
amount of time and there's limited
number of topics that might come up and
so uh I guess I suggest that we as
humans have a very sort of uh shallow
understanding of one another
and sort of knowledge of others states
of mind and when things are digitized we
can have superpowers that we've never
had before to be able to understand each
other
like forget digital assistant just the
ability to say let's again voluntarily
we both have to enable it let's overlay
our mental models
and and this thing can detect where we
have things in common where we have
differences where we have
misunderstandings
just one thing on that though um we'll
get to the overlaying the minds in a
second but um there's a phrase that once
you know someone and you start to see
through them so there's something about
the Mystique there's something about not
being able to predict what the person's
going to say that kind of makes them
interesting and endearing and do you
think that we run the risk of kind of
losing that Mystique
I don't think so I I think that we just
get to go deeper with people rather than
having the Mystique be sort of in the
shallows of you know you two like to
play tennis
Chuck we get to sort of skip all of that
and said great we both love to play
tennis and go into sort of much deeper
places like I think it's human nature to
want to understand other
humans and and uh
as we were talking earlier I think
there's sort of the depth of the human
mind is is extraordinarily uh deep and
uh so I I don't think that that's really
going to be an issue like I mean I I've
heard sort of arguments like that made
before for you know Serendipity in
dating for example right like or you go
to a dating site and you sort of dial in
a person but wouldn't it be better if
you just sort of randomly ran across
them on the street
I'm not sure that's that's true uh in
fact I I think or same thing with
whatever getting access to information
right like before search engines your
sort of serendipitously be at a place
where you would have discovered
something and now as soon as it's
digitized it's sort of much easier we
haven't run out of things to learn and
so I think this will be the same kind of
a of a dynamic
yeah I'm torn on that because I agree
with Kenneth Stanley we interviewed him
he read a book called why greatness
cannot be planned and he was talking all
about how Serendipity plays an outsized
role in our lives and I agree with you
that in a sense their mind is is
insanely complex but it depends on the
level of resolution and that was kind of
where I was going with that spectrum of
specificity because while there are some
general principles so on a dating
website you you do tend to match People
based on their rough attractiveness and
age and interest and so on but but then
there's this huge spectrum of of kind of
creative Serendipity and um yeah I just
think that's if you think about the
exponential blow up when you get all of
these different situational features
that kind of come together and they
behave in unpredictable ways that's when
you get the chaos totally look no no
sorry I hope I didn't miscommunicate I I
think this provides opportunity for more
and deeper serendipity
than sort of random Serendipity the
ability to uh get get into the the
interesting things with people that you
may have never gotten into because you
were sort of stuck in shallows and
didn't realize there was like all of
this interesting things about that
person that you can discover
serendipitously still uh you you may
have passed them by on the street then
sort of not spend time with them or
whatever you're sitting on a park bench
with them and you started to have small
talk and then all of a sudden
you know wandered off but didn't realize
this person was sitting next to had all
kinds of amazing things for you to
discover beyond that and so you need
sort of a tease of that perhaps like I
don't think we'll ever be able to like
uh
let me take that back I think we might
be able to it's sort of a you know in
time to to get all of this so that most
Serendipity sort of disappears and
you'll be able to see through a person I
I wonder if humans will sort of
prior to that sort of create some ways
to say this stuff you don't get to see
and the stuff you do get to see we've
kind of already thought of that we're
going to release a people matching app
that does specifically what I was just
telling you which like lets you overlay
your mental model with someone else or
in groups to be able to see how groups
sort of uh think and and where there's
alignment and misalignment and part of
that there's going to be the ability to
say look this information is sort of not
shareable or shareable in different
tiers I can sort of
ratchet it up depending on how
comfortable I feel with you of like how
much I I share of my of my debts
yeah yeah so um almost like planes of
privacy so you have these different
concentric circles and and you say
um this is my public profile this is my
work profile the only thing with that
though is we're dealing with algorithms
that can find you know surface
correlations in all sorts of things that
you are unaware of and you might
inadvertently be revealing things about
yourself without realizing absolutely
yeah I think I think there's going to be
uh
lots of lots of new uh problems to solve
as as we start to to see kind of what's
Happening once people get some of this
data out
okay okay
um just before we move back to the
Privacy thing we haven't really spoken
about some of the downstream
applications so so you guys have built
this entire engine for profiling and
indexing a mind and then people can
build applications on the end of it and
you've built a bunch of them already so
could you just talk about you know some
of the potential applications that
people could build and how they would do
that
yeah so
um today uh
the platform isn't available for
third-party developers to be able
to build applications on top of it but
certainly that is planned for the future
um
next year feels like probably the the
time where we will start to address that
um our team prior to building uai
actually built a developer platform
called Koji that allows third-party
developers to very rapidly build
applications
and also have access to sort of shared
data and and shared services payments
things like that
um so today the applications that we
have and have planned are all first
party applications
from the vantage point where we are now
and I'm certain that things will change
as as we move forward both for us and
for other people to be able to see more
clearly you know what applications could
be built utilizing data like this
um we see three areas that
um
seem obvious sort of one area is uh sort
of personal where I can use this data
that I'm digitizing pulling out of my
mind and the system could help me better
understand myself
and that could be everything sort of
from visualizations that are created
that sort of potentially render like
imagine like a force-directed graph of
some of these you know beliefs that I
might have and how they're related to
other beliefs and I can start to
visualize uh how sort of the inside of
my mind works uh so things like that or
things that feel kind of like therapy
for example that can take a bunch of
this data that I've pulled out and then
be able to potentially suggest to me
that I might have some propensity for
one thing or some deficiency or some
gaps in knowledge so like a lot of
things where I can learn about myself
by digitizing my mind so that's sort of
one set of applications another set is
um
really sort of human to human
communication
sort of
two humans as we were just talking about
the ability to Overlay our mental model
with another human and be able to
understand each other better
or group applications where you know
when people work in teams or various
groups of people
communication and Alignment
sort of is our our challenges
and and you know many times I can point
to sort of frustration of trying to
align a team of people and and spending
time in meetings and writing documents
and and sort of asking them are we
aligned then they would say yes we're
aligned and I'd say great tell me what
it is we're doing so I can understand
that we're aligned and they're able to
say the words that feel like we're
aligned and then all of a sudden for
some reason it feels like we're
executing not an alignment right not
growing in the same direction why is
that I think again I think it's because
these sort of situations that we find
ourselves in whether they're meetings or
whatever conversations uh we describe
sort of a point in time something that
is an outcome or some path
but uh the vantage point from which we
are speaking sort of the vector on which
we're looking at it and conceiving it
actually aren't aligned and so when we
describe our intersection we think we
are but as we see sort of action it's
not and so we believe that there can be
a bunch of applications that can take
all of this data and test for alignment
test for understanding of you know goals
and and uh
gaps and knowledge and things like that
and sort of Team Dynamics so that's
certainly another area that we think
there's lots of applications to be built
and then the third area is really this
using this data to be able to interface
with with the world of digital
and I think it should be clear to to
people that
at this moment humans are the bottleneck
and being able to leverage all of this
Innovation and information technology
like I think we passed that sort of
Crossroads a while back like they're
countless applications that I could be
using should be using that would make me
better happier more productive Etc but I
have no time or sort of ability to be
able to leverage all those applications
and so what good is it that we get more
innovation
if if humans sort of can't leverage it
or in another example you get sort of
these amazing new things with these
generative AI models and all you have to
do is tell them what to do in a text box
you know with your thumbs because most
of us are on mobile
that doesn't seem like the right
interface to be able to leverage all the
power sort of to wield the power of
these new information Technologies we
believe uh a better approach is to sort
of meet them where they are meaning to
to turn ourselves into digital
and then I'll allow ourselves to take
this sort of data set that we've teased
out of our mind and and Grant it to
technologies that can take either a
bunch of raw data
and and be able to do something with it
meaning find structure in it and and be
able to then leverage this
multi-dimensional
um set of data or you know data that's
been formatted and and then can sort of
be used in these various different
services and so you can imagine
um if you're trying to book a trip to
Disneyland you know today you have you
might go to chat GPT and do some
ideation then you might go to Google and
verify that you know these things
actually exist and you're not sort of
getting a bunch of hallucinations then
you got to do sort of a bunch of
research and Price shopping and
comparison and calendaring with you and
your you know travel partners and and
communication all of that and all of
that is being done by you
but people who are
you know much wealthier than I am uh
have personal assistance and so if they
want to go to Disneyland they can just
say hey Bob I want to take the family to
Disneyland and Bob can go off and do all
of that because Bob can sort of make
countless assumptions about me and my
family because Bob understands me in my
family and then sort of synthesize all
of that and summarize it and come back
and say look there are really three
viable options and here are the pros and
cons of each and I can then sort of take
those and you know confer with my wife
and say Bob will take option b and then
Bob could go off and interact with all
of these services
and and sort of execute these various
steps in order to be able to do that and
whether that's completely autonomous or
that is Bob proposing and I say yes go
go go go go go you know I think all of
these things will depend on like what
what is the action and and how much
these systems are effective at being
able to do that without errors
yeah and um I like that option of making
it semi-interactive because if it was
completely non-interactive then the
potential for misalignment would be
higher that you could identify the
dimensions where there is most
uncertainty and then have this kind of
interactive process to hone in on on the
true alignment
um you mentioned so many interesting
things there actually and so many I
wanted to actually speak about
um almost all of them maybe we should
start with the group alignment thing in
the office because I think that's very
interesting
um I can attest to this personally the
amount of countless hours that have been
wasted you know what it's like in a
business there's no grown-ups in the
room there's lots of misalignments and
um in my startup company we even all had
a personality profile to help us get on
with each other better and my uh co-host
Keith Duggar he's quite low on empathy
and he's very pedantic and it's very
very easy to kind of get emotional and
to misinterpret the intention behind an
action right and it's one of those
things that just like when you're in a
relationship with a wife over many many
years you start to actually understand
the causes the reason for the behavior
and it makes you interpret the situation
completely differently it's like when
you're when your baby spills some food
over the floor you know there's no Mal
intent there it's just a baby and then
you kind of interpret the situation
differently but but the only question
there though is there's so much
complexity in our personality profiles
so and where where I also want to go of
this is sometimes this information is
not in the data so it's not deducible
from the textual interactions we have
which is why you're coming at it from
this additional top-down approach which
is creating a structure and asking
specific questions to try and divide up
that personality space but it still
seems like there might be a bit of a gap
in the Middle where you might still not
be able to represent the new ones
I I think that's absolutely true so
there's a bunch of things there one is
personality tests like Myers-Briggs for
example and there's like a bunch of
other of these assessments right
psychological assessments are are
crafted with
some hypothesis in mind and then
people go through these tests in order
to sort of like in a tree structure in
order to bucket themselves into sort of
like one bucket or another bucket
um
and and while those are sort of valuable
they are you know quite low in
resolution
and you sort of get crudely lumped into
this sort of stereotype in a sense of
caricature and obviously humans are
infinitely more complex than that and so
the approach we're taking sort of first
thing that's different is is that it is
not like a personality test it you know
like it does not have sort of something
in mind to try to bucket you in it's
simply a bunch of data points right give
presented with this prompt this user
engaged with it in this way and when you
get a bunch of these data points sort of
compared to a digital images made of
pixels
right and and sort of one pixel doesn't
say much 100 pixels don't say much but
when you get many pixels you can start
to see an image initially low resolution
but the more pixels there there are the
higher resolution it is this too in a
sense is doing that except it's going to
do it in Vector space
and and so it's not a digital image sort
of flat image but a bunch of data points
that can then sort of be
differentiate you from me for example
right and then some places we will be
quite aligned and in other places we
will be potentially Polar Opposites and
uh so I think there's really sort of uh
a spectrum of
this alignment and and how we'll get
there initially it's going to be quite
crude which is uh if you take a a group
of people and you give them a bunch of
prompts and imagine like these prompts
are about a project that we're all
working on and so these problems could
be created by again one of our team
members or potentially be even generated
these days by
let's say a large language model sort of
given given some some context about the
things that we're working on it can
generate a bunch of prompts to see if we
are in alignment uh and those problems
could be sort of as crude as like what
success look like
and and given sort of multiple choice
and pick all the things that apply right
multi-select multiple choice what is it
that we're trying to do here and I'm
certain again in my experience from
having built three venture-backed
companies and and worked at Google in
Myspace on large teams that when you get
a team of people and you give them a
bunch of questions like that that you
will find anomalies where people will
miss it and say pick other things and
that should be quite easy to just
attacked again no machine learning
required and say look we're misaligned
here and and by the way then can go and
sort of Remedy that situation
um and then uh and again imagine that
with sort of many prompts in in
different uh prompt templates in
different ways with disambiguation and
things like that so there's a lot of
work that can be done just with you know
sort of very simple uh group prompting
uh and then over time as these things
get more intelligent and you start to
build models that can really sort of
take a bunch of these data points and
find sort of Dimensions that have
nothing to do with sort of explicit
misalignment but but can deal with you
know some things that again we might be
able to see it on data and not be able
to even have a label for it because we
won't exactly understand you know what's
happening in the misalignment but
certainly statistically it's showing
that there's something there
and again that could be things like
attitude and and you know a person could
be going through some you know personal
issues at the time they might be
distracted like there are all these
things that you can't really capture in
in language and and questions but that
can be seen uh in in sort of anomalies
of um
of data
yeah um I was just thinking as well it's
quite similar to in um moral Frameworks
you know you have uh deontological
principles which is that you know thou
shall not kill or there are just certain
principles that that I adhere to and
then there's kind of consequentialism
which is that there are certain
um outcomes that that I don't like so
sometimes the the ends might justify the
means and I guess with alignment as you
were just talking to there's behaviors
and there's goals and principles and so
many different things and we have to
kind of construct this alignment space
and some of it might not be deducible
from the data it might it might come
from different things but this reminds
me a little bit of this um area called
Quantified Self I'm not sure if you've
heard of that but I used to every day I
kept a mind diary
and I recorded how I was feeling on the
day and every day I had to create a new
category because it was slightly nuanced
in all of the previous 300 categories
didn't quite cover it and very similar
with language processing you know like
human rules don't really work very well
for this kind of thing and we need to
have neural network models that can see
patterns that perhaps we couldn't in you
know Intuit or understand
um so yeah I think there's something
really interesting there yeah look uh I
often explain to people that even though
we're called uai uh you could very much
think of us as being sort of in the
field of Quantified Self
like this is what you're doing by
digitizing your mind is is you are
quantifying your mental models
um and speaking of Lex Friedman I
recently saw Brian Johnson uh on on
Lex's show and and they were talking
about uh kernel flow this like helmet
that Colonel has been developing uh I'm
not sure if if uh viewers uh know this
there's really two companies that are
doing really interesting thing one
companies called neurolink which is an
Elon Musk company that that has a brain
implant uh that they haven't brought to
market yet but as in research that sort
of allows uh
there to be stimuli presented to people
and then sort of measuring uh brain
waves and and electromagnetic sort of
in-chemical reactions in human brains
and then being able to digitize that and
then Brian Johnson's company which is
Kernel with a k
and uh they've got this like helmet that
you put on and uh it uh it uses light
sort of the same thing as we do with the
Apple watch and and sort of monitors you
know blood flow in in the human skull uh
as stimuli is presented and digitizes it
and and you know potentially will have
some applications in the future uh you
could look at us as doing something
similar except while those two companies
are focused on the human brain
and sort of require Hardware we are
focused on on the mind and require no
Hardware uh meaning you a phone or or a
computer and and sort of using uh you
know eyes and ears and and other sensors
we have to be able to get access to
what's inside our head
yeah but I'd like to explore that a
little bit because in a way it's a
distinction without a difference now you
know when Andy Clark came up with this
concept called the extended mind which
is that our phone is an extended mind
and you're talking about the the extreme
end of the spectrum where you actually
have a neural implant and you can do
something that I think it's referred to
as neural feedback where indirect
response to some stimuli you get a
strong signal and you can change your
behavior whereas with this technology
there's a bit of a gap I'll look at my
virtual assistant and it will give me
some some guidance and the only I guess
I can see it in a good way in a bad way
so when I work with with Keith for
example
um we now are like a married couple and
I understand if we're going down a bad
path and I can kind of I can change it
very quickly like when you meditate you
learn that here is a thought train it's
going in a bad place I'm just going to
press the stop button right now and it's
all about making that process that
reflexive process more and more
efficient and you can argue that that
it's a good thing but you you could also
argue that in a way it kind of removes
some of the the character and creativity
of life because it creates this
consensus do you know what I mean it it
kind of like removes some of the spark
in a way
uh
I think
certainly there's a part of that that's
true which is when you
um have worked with somebody for a long
time like I worked with my co-founder
Sean now for
um seven years full-time and then
another two years sort of part-time and
we
can say very few words and be able to
describe a tremendous amount of of sort
of implied things that that don't need
to be said and so it's a really sort of
magical communication
uh uh but then on the other hand again
it feels like it's it you know it's
limited because we sort of instantly go
into that and and might have a hard time
sort of uh
breaking out of of that kind of a
pattern but but at the same time again I
I think the more
the the more we can
digitize the more we can sort of use
digital also to potentially sort of
propose expanding uh the whether it's a
again a project that we're working on
that can then sort of be expanded
digitally and get us to think in
different ways and sort of like prompt
us to be able to do that pull us out of
our sort of natural tendencies
um
yeah I you know I think hard to predict
what happens when we humans get these
new capabilities we've never had them
before we've never had the capability to
instantly know so much about a person or
to be able to realize that the people
that we've been dealing with this whole
time you know our friends and family and
colleagues all of a sudden now we see
tremendous amount more resolution about
them and start to see things that might
feel I think it might actually end up
feeling a little bit like when you get a
a high definition TV versus sort of a a
standard TV all of a sudden everything
looks sort of like a soap opera because
everything is is uh is now HD and so I
think we might experience a similar
feeling uh for a bit when when this
happens but at the same time you yeah I
guess I'm a believer that the higher
resolution is better
yeah so so many things to touch on there
it's genuinely mysterious and I like you
am fascinated by let's say the the
um the potential for GPT my type models
to be pedagogical and to help us with
education and some people say they make
us lazy and they make us disengaged and
they certainly change the way that you
do educate yourself because now you can
ask increasingly specific questions and
you can go directly to the information
you need whereas before you might have
had a top-down exploratory process and
there's actually many counterfactual
paths that you explored that did not
lead anywhere interesting but there's
still something interesting about
exploring those counterfactual paths and
similarly when you get to know someone
um first of all it's in many cases it's
not good to know them completely at the
beginning because you might not even
want to be friends with them in the
first place if you knew too much so
there's it needs to be partially
observable and then there's something
about exploring bad Pathways many times
and learning your lesson and oh I've
been stung once so I'm not going to go
there and again it's like when you when
you bring up your children you've
learned so many lessons in life you've
been around the Sun so many times and
you want to stop them from doing stupid
things but you can't lead a horse to
water right you know you they have to
make their own mistakes and I guess like
there's an element of something now I'm
not don't want to call it paternalism
but to what extent do people need to
kind of like make their own mistakes
uh I don't know but I have five kids and
uh the oldest one is nine and and so I I
feel like I live in a research lab of of
you know cognitive development uh I
certainly like other parents have the
Instinct of uh
wanting them not to make
um you know bad mistakes obviously uh
but realizing that allowing them to make
mistakes is extremely important I I
don't think that that any of this
whether it's llms or the work we're
doing with with digitizing the Mind
needs to necessarily preclude that uh in
fact it could sort of instrument that it
could intentionally be sort of smarter
instead of sort of just general
serendipitous lessons in hardship making
mistakes this thing can present
situations and have you learn a lesson
verify that you've learned a lesson if
you have not yet learned the lesson find
other ways to be able to get you to
learn the lesson like we can be
intelligent about being able to create
those types of of stimuli and
opportunities for humans to
to learn lessons whether they're kids or
or adults
um
so I think there's like a lot of
interesting stuff uh there on the side
of of education so I was a really poor
student uh I I you know now that I'm an
adult I can blame all kinds of things
and give it labels like add and things
like that but generally I I think I was
bored and and I'm interested and I I
tend to learn in a way where I want to
choose the next sort of thing to look at
and so like learning by
um conversationally in in chatting with
an llm
is awesome right it's sort of The Next
Step Beyond like what we've gotten with
YouTube which I can jump from video to
video and hear people talk about the
same concept from different angles and
like so that also has been like
transformative for me just following a
teacher's reasoning uh has always been a
struggle for me and you know many other
people that I know but I actually think
there's something much more powerful
that comes from
um
specifically mind digitization uh when
it comes to learning I think the biggest
problem uh sort of in this Dimension
that humans have is we don't know what
we don't know
and and we we might craft some queries
some prompts for llms to try to figure
out this thing that we think we're
trying to figure out but we really don't
even know how to craft the prompts and
we obviously have limited time also and
so there's like only so much time you
can spend on that but if we digitize our
minds and again as this
digitization algorithm in a sense gets
more sophisticated as I mentioned
earlier today it's just completely done
but as it gets smart it should be able
to detect our you know sort of knowledge
graph of our own mind
and then be able to find gaps in
knowledge and then be able to
proactively
sort of synthesize
materials and and present them to us in
sort of the things like a jigsaw puzzle
like this Mega dimensional jigsaw puzzle
of our of our knowledge graph uh and and
sort of create learnings that connect
the subject to things that we already
know in in this personalized way and so
completely personalized learning
materials
content generation
and by the way if that's the case then
you start to potentially extrapolate
from that then and you could get to a
place where it feels like there's no
reason for anyone to create websites
anymore or for Content human content
creators to create content because now
the machine can create custom content
for each one of us
on the Fly
and and that might be radically more
compelling and productive and uh
obviously would fundamentally change uh
what the internet is and how we how we
use it and and you know implications for
now
tens of millions actually over 100
million people who see themselves as
being content creators
I know there's a famous meme where you
have someone using GPT to generate an
email and then someone on the other side
uses GPT to summarize the email and the
email just becomes this kind of
redundant artifact and yeah it is going
to be like that in terms of consuming
content but then you get this weird
situation where the models are built on
the content and most of the content will
be generated in the future so where does
the fresh content come from but I wanted
to touch on something you said as well
just quickly which is um yeah I'm
fascinated by education and I think I'm
one of the luckiest people alive because
we grew up in the traditional system and
we know what's interesting right because
a big part of it is the Discrimination
we we know what the areas of
interestingness are we've been educated
and I can go on GPT and I can explore
the philosophy of mind all sorts of
different topics I'm interested in if
you're a kid growing up now what do you
actually do if you have a complete Blank
Slate right how do you actually find
something interesting to start drilling
into and that's the dichotomy I think
between discrimination and and
generation
I think that the the real opportunity in
these generative AI models is not for us
humans to ask them to do things and and
they do them that's obviously
extraordinarily compelling and countless
implications for productivity and
creativity and all of that but sort of
to turn that around and you know for
example if if I was to meet a genie and
the genie said you can ask me you know I
know everything you can ask me any
question you want
I believe the right question to ask the
genie is what what question should I ask
you
what don't I know that I should know
and and have the genie sort of Take the
Lead and say aha that's the right
question well but for me to answer that
question I'd need to better understand
you and so let me ask you a bunch of
questions and then I'll figure out what
you know what you don't know and then be
able to to sort of prompt you now with
uh new capabilities of like which of
these things do you find interesting for
example and now we can go in and learn
these things
does that make sense yeah but oh it does
yeah I think the the only pushback on
that is there's an infinite number of
potentially interesting things and even
now if you look at people's interests
it's not uniformly distributed
um there's a huge weight towards for
example skills and interests which would
make you valuable on the market so
everyone wants to be a software engineer
and learn artificial intelligence and
perhaps not work in the local hospital
or something like that so but I guess I
don't know whether that could be
balanced out in some way if if it was
different
I think so
uh again I I think today when we
humans are the ones in control that are
driving sort of our Spotlight of you
know where do we shine it to try to
learn more about something we are driven
by
um
sort of all kinds of uh uh
uh things that we try to optimize for
and optimizing for having a you know a
lucrative career is a is a strong force
and therefore drives people to spend
their time focused on learning new
skills in that
um
but if if again if things could be
turned around and now not only can they
do that and sort of guide it but they
start to get a bunch of proposals of
other things that might be interesting
for them to learn and perhaps that could
also influence positively this other
thing that they wanted to learn sort of
indirectly
uh I think you can imagine all kinds of
applications that that create shortcuts
and and give us back a bunch of our time
and being able to to learn stuff like
for example there are a lot of people
now that are studying to be prompt
Engineers right like that's like really
interesting like all of these videos
that have come out and and courses for
for people to learn to speak to to an
llm
um
it and then people okay fine so I want
to be a prompt engineer and then you
know they go and they start to go into
the weeds and like they look up gradient
descent and and they start sort of
refreshing their math skills and and
going into all these other things that
are really completely irrelevant
to being able to to create prompts like
it doesn't help you any of you
understand gradient descent to be able
to then craft a better prompt I believe
uh and that should be made clear to
people uh uh and could be where today
when they're the ones in the driver's
seat they have no real ability to be
able to discern what you know what
things are relevant what things are not
relevant and and how to sort of connect
all of this
on on that though that that nicely
dovetails with the point I was going to
make which is that um I mean growing up
I've done so many stupid things and a
lot of it is because I behaved
irrationally and I wish I could just go
back and tell myself you know and I I
knew I was being irrational I just did a
stupid thing and I needed someone to
tell me look you know you should be
doing that why have you done this driven
by your emotion or whatever but the
prompt engineering one is quite an
interesting one because sometimes there
are hidden rationalizations
so the reason why prompt Engineers learn
about gradient descent is because they
want to Signal
um on social media that they have
technical chops to distinguish
themselves and that's quite a common
pattern so they don't need to know it
totally totally yeah yeah no that that's
for sure look there I there are all
kinds of uh reasons that that uh
people go into uh
what are various areas and and and sort
of play around and and and uh
get a little bit of depth depth of
knowledge and then sort of move on and
say okay this isn't relevant to me I'll
go somewhere else
uh but again I don't think that any of
this really precludes that in fact I
mean sort of like the temperature
parameter and the null Alum right like
you can introduce chaos
into into systems
and you know either sort of true chaos
where you sort of randomly in a sense go
in and and find new distractions that
might be interesting and dive in or sort
of more intelligent chaos that might uh
feel like chaos but at the end of the
day you know it's all sort of
orchestrated to get you into a a healthy
State whatever it is that you choose to
be a healthy State like I think that
still should be human choice we all
shouldn't be in a sense manipulated to
become like everyone else and and sort
of all-knowing on all of these areas
that are valuable for humans too if
you're talking sort of about education
sort of knowledge that everybody sort of
knows the same things uh I think one of
the challenges here is going to be is as
we digitize our minds and as this thing
prompts us to be able to uh understand
our our desires our human desires
and and help us get there and help us
achieve those things that it is that we
uh you know feel like we're trying to
achieve
yeah yeah there's a magic balance of
entropy and and energy to coin Carl
friston's free energy principle and
there are there are certain pressures in
in society which cause a kind of
converging effect and I think having
just the right amount of chaos and and
Divergence keeps the whole system
interesting but I wanted to move over a
little bit to some of the privacy and
the text stuff so um yeah you're asking
some um in some cases quite personal
questions and I just wonder could you
just go through your privacy policy and
how is that information stored and
shared if at all yeah so uh it is uh all
of it is still in the works so we have
an alpha privacy policy in this as the
system evolves we will evolve with that
as well
um generally you know we think obviously
it's really important to to follow best
practices in information security and
privacy and so everything in the system
is encrypted there's access controls uh
no team members of uai have any access
to your data no nor will they
um
all users are are um you know sort of
private all we require from you right
now to log in as an email address and
the password if you are really sensitive
about privacy you might want to create a
fresh email address and only use that
for uh for the system if you want to go
next level you might want to connect
with VPN so like I think we allow humans
to sort of choose their levels of
privacy there uh today no one sort of no
other user knows that you exist as a
user and so you're sort of truly
invisible and Anonymous uh we there's a
prompt in there it says what should I
call you it was intentionally made to
say that rather than what is your name
right and so you can sort of choose
whatever you want and so I think at the
end of the day the human is in control
of how much data they digitize
and and how much they sort of trust the
system
we obviously understand that's going to
be sort of Cornerstone of people feel
uncomfortable
with being able uh to do that
um sort of beyond that uh you know their
approaches again we haven't implemented
them yet but like sort of differential
privacy or synthetic data and things
like that that will uh as you start to
get into sort of potentially again
third-party applications using this and
and other things that sort of real data
isn't shared uh you get synthetic data
that sort of
represents uh the the data set uh but
with with
um uh sort of ambiguity there of of
hudas and and so you can never really
trace it back to to people but again all
of that it's really sort of in the early
days here now
okay okay yeah because um I guess if
you're using something like
um open ai's API behind the scenes that
doesn't store any data so then I guess
the main the main thing I would pick up
on is if you are in any way leaking or
sharing information between the
customers
is is it just completely isolated at the
moment it is completely isolated yeah
the only time that information might be
shared between customers is when you
voluntarily again like some of these
applications that I proposed where you
are comparing yourself to other people
uh where you voluntarily explicitly say
I would like to sort of overlay data and
there you'll have these like different
uh layers of of privacy that you'll get
to choose
awesome so the killer question is and
it's okay if you're not allowed to
answer this but which back end llm are
you using
uh no I'm happy to answer it so uh right
now it's uh it's uh chat GPT it's The
DaVinci API uh that we're using and
um
actually as of yesterday we are uh also
integrating Claude via API so anthropics
model as well but again we really see
ourselves as being sort of model
agnostic
um as as uh there are more models that
are created more sort of apis available
uh we'll integrate to those and and
again depends on whether human sort of
manually gets to choose what model
they're interacting with or there's some
intelligence that sort of potentially by
the way could use multiple models
simultaneously and and can find
correlations and disambiguation and some
models might be not might be I'm certain
will be stronger in in you know some
respects and other models in other
respects we sort of feel like we are uh
sitting
um and it's like really special Vantage
Point sort of closest to the user
closest to the human to be able to
assist the human again to leverage like
all of this
power of Information Technology and and
I also don't believe that it's simply
like everything goes simply to us
speaking to large language models like
there'll be other services that are
available that might be the right
services to communicate with that have
nothing to do necessarily with language
booking services to book your travel
blah blah
uh where uh you know sort of a chat
interface even with like plugins and
things like that is sort of not the most
effective interface to be able to to
leverage that and so uh we'll see as we
move forward like how all of that
develops yeah
yeah I mean a few things on that
absolutely so we need to have an
intermediate service which can use tools
you can access my calendar it can send
emails it can do this that and the other
it's plugged into all of the things that
I use on anthropic I finally got access
to it yesterday uh the um the 100K
context model my God it's beautiful
although unfortunately I was a little
bit let down because
um I pasted an entire Stanford Plato
article in I think on computationalism
earlier and it was beautifully
summarizing answering questions and so
on and I guess I just assumed that it
was perfectly you know looking at
everything in the context window I
pasted in a two-hour interview that I
did yesterday on mlst and I told it to
generate a table of contents and it only
seemed to be aware of the last 40
minutes in the conversation so because I
knew what was in that conversation I
could immediately see that it was it had
blind spots so um I think apparently
they're using The Alibi model to do that
that context and you know to work on a
large to context so they probably need
to do a bit of work there but anyway I
mean in principle having a large context
window is amazing for you guys because
you can just stick an entire book of
information in there about the person
for sure and and you know we we believe
that all those context windows are going
to get larger and larger uh over time I
mean there's probably some limit but but
still uh feels like we're not there uh
and then we can also sort of do in the
process sort of summarization and and
and sort of get some if it's starting to
hit the limit get it to summarize and
sort of reduce the the dimensions and
and reprompt itself with
with a summary rather than sort of an
explicit list and I seem to do that well
so um you've built this entire pipeline
you've got people using it and I guess
the question is are you evaluating in
any way what the lift is
so yeah tell me about that have you
designed any evaluations so well you
mean the lift in in sort of the the
personalization and the output of the
model uh how different is it from
yeah I mean it's not talking to me how
you would measure is it relevance or
satisfaction or something like that so
you know but perhaps you could I don't
know if you've done a b testing or
something and here's here's without the
personalized information how much of an
improvement does it does it yield
we've uh we've done some some
qualitative not quantitative uh testing
of that both uh obviously with our team
and also we have over 2500 people now in
the alpha that are using it and
around 700 people in Discord
and and so again there's some
qualitative reports of uh Lyft uh I
think you know all of it is is quite
subjective until somebody sort of
potentially spent some time to really
develop
um some sort of more objective
benchmarking for for uh the sort of
Delta and personalization and not
personalization uh and it might also be
sort of a placebo effect that is in play
where people might feel like this
whatever give me a movie recommendation
and you could say it just to chat GPT
and it'll give you a movie
recommendation and you can pass it a
bunch of sort of parameters and as
context and say give me a movie
recommendation gives you something else
and you might look at that and say Well
they're both great movies and but but
they're different and so it sort of did
something different and you can even get
it to explain to you like why it sort of
used these different parameters and why
beliefs that uh that this is the right
recommendation but is is that the right
recommendation or not that's it's hard
to tell I think in general sort of with
recommendation uh that that's sort of
always been an issue like are the
YouTube recommendations we're getting
the right ones
um
they're better than no recommendations
although to the conversation we were
having earlier you kind of lose that
Serendipity of sort of like randomly
getting stuff thrown at you and uh and
get into
you know Echo Chambers
Dynamics
yeah and there's a few interesting
things there as well and I'm sure you've
seen tree of thought and process
reasoning from open Ai and increasingly
there are ways of prompting these models
where instead of just giving you the
answer they give you the entire you know
step-by-step process of reasoning and of
course that's an intelligible
explanation as well that that you can
give in in your Downstream assistant
yeah in fact I I've seen some of the uh
sort of research on on those being sort
of really important and in in prompt
engineering of of getting it to sort of
go step by step and sort of say you know
use use this methodology to be able to
to respond to me
um this app that we will be launching uh
I think it's going to be called context
this ability for
um
users to show up and and create this
collection of prompts and then sort of
manipulate uh a preamble
uh for prompt engineer and and sort of
have a uh an IDE type interface uh that
allows you to test different preambles
and and context and and sort of fine
tune that
and then sort of package that for any
person to show up and not have to do
that work all they have to do is engage
with the prompts and now they've
configured this like very sophisticated
uh uh prompt that would go and hit
whatever any of these large language
models that we integrate to I think
we'll find all kinds of sort of exciting
things happening with people playing
around with those types of approaches
you need to call it mind Studio
that would be uh
um but I mean one of the cool things
there is again on Quantified Self
um I don't know whether you've noticed
that the Apple Health app
it doesn't really give you any any
useful actionable information it just
gives you your average heart rate and
your sleep patterns and so on and it's
all very boring and the reason for that
of course is it's very open to
interpretation there's lots of
contextual stuff there but one thing you
could really do to help people is as
well as having this information actually
give them give them intelligible and
actionable explanations for for what it
means totally let's move on to some of
the slightly more philosophical topics
because our audience loves all of that
so um do you remember that service
replica where you could have a digital
girlfriend and many of those folks
developed emotional um relationships
with these non-biological entities and
then they famously restricted the
service and all of the girlfriends died
and everyone was up up in arms about it
I mean do you think
you know we're moving towards a world
now where increasingly the line is going
to blur between digital minds and real
minds and that seems to come with some
responsibility
responsibility for the model creators
the responsibility for the humans that
are engaging with the replicas and
I would argue both because if you argued
as Daniel Dennett might argue that these
are digital minds they're replicas they
in some sense There's no distinction
between the digital mind and a real
human being therefore you can't really
just turn it off if people have
developed attachments to it
totally I I uh my mom develops
attachments to sort of inanimate objects
and for example a car that we used to
own and and when we were selling the car
she felt like this heartbreak of uh this
car sort of leaving the the family and
so I think that's sort of a human
condition that we develop attachments to
all kinds of things obviously other
humans it's an obvious one but inanimate
object so in this case uh you know
synthetic humans let's let's call it
sort of like these sophisticated models
that that
feel very human-like uh and and I think
this is sort of a new
um
you know
a new set of problems that that we will
be exploring of of you know what does
that mean that if you're attached to
this thing and all of a sudden it goes
away there's obviously grief and loss
and these emotions and uh and on one
hand those might seem like negative
emotions on the other hand those are
wonderful emotions right that's what it
means to be human
to feel that and many people you know
for whatever reason might not have
access to other humans that will break
their heart
and in this case the the AI models might
serve that purpose and and teach them
valuable lessons and get their
endorphins going and in various ways
I know but we don't want to break
people's hearts I mean I I agree with
you that suffering is part of the human
condition and that that's part of the
the Journey of learning in many ways but
I don't want it I don't want to
insinuate that you're trivializing it by
comparing it to inanimate objects but
there are people who believe that if you
do create a replica of a digital mind
which is to say and this is an
interesting side thing by the way that
um psychologists now are using the
language of psychology to understand how
language models work and there's even
people seriously writing papers about
them having a theory of mind and goals
and beliefs and there are other people
so talking about existential threats of
course but
um you know in in some sense this is
really different to an inanimate object
of course of course yeah no the only
reason I was bringing that up is is just
to say that that uh attachment in in
sort of uh ability to connect with uh
whatever is inside of us it's human
nature and so give given something that
as as powerful and sort of compelling as
you know an artificial intelligence that
feels very human
um
certainly stimulates you know that
natural tendency in us to to find
connection
uh with it and and this is obviously a
new a new capability that's never
existed and so we will explore what
happens when when you sort of do this at
scale
okay so um I know you listen to the
Denna interview and I asked him a
similar question so when I spoke with
Luciano floridi he spoke about the risks
of reintologization and I know that I'm
trying to avoid the the philosophical
buzzwords but he basically says that
we're moving from a physical world into
an informational world you know which is
to say that the best lens to understand
our reality now is an informational one
and if you think about it our digital
identities are becoming diffused and
they're kind of more important than our
physical identities and what does that
mean you know for our kind of value and
self-worth in this Society
yeah uh another term that I think uh
relates to this is a metaverse
um yeah you know I think General
generally when when you say the word
metaverse people tend to imagine like
you know 3D VR type worlds but but I
submit that that's actually not the sort
of interesting part of matter verse I
believe metaverse is what we've been
living in since
really I think since uh
the beginnings of Facebook where we
started using real names on social media
and where the our digital identities
started to have real sort of value or or
be detrimental potentially to our our
you know place in society and so I
believe we sort of live in the matter
verse now where I it is clear uh that
for many of us including myself
um our digital identities are
extraordinarily important and for some
people more important than sort of the
the real world
um
and uh
and it obviously AI takes us even deeper
in into that kind of a world
do you think that Facebook has been a
Force for good
I I think it's uh it's been on one hand
a uh an incredible Force for good of
allowing people to communicate with
other people that they would have lost
touch with to ReDiscover people that
they had lost touch with and and again
sort of maintain relationships over time
the ability to better understand people
and communicate with sort of the
abstraction layer of digital and and be
able to bring up subjects that might be
uh too tender to bring up in in physical
world but
behind the screen it's easier but that
same thing obviously has caused a
tremendous amount of of harm because as
soon as you start to allow people to uh
do that same thing that I was just
talking about they've sort of use the
the
abstraction of digital to be able to to
bring up tender things they can get out
of hand and and you know all of the
algorithmic issues uh that happen when
you optimize because Facebook is a
business no matter where you optimize
for engagement and and you know
advertising dollars these algorithms
start to
um
incentivized behavior and uh that that's
not uh beneficial to to people and uh
you know forget sort of the Cambridge
analytica hack that really impacted the
U.S elections so uh it's everything is
Yin in Yang I think you know to have the
good you have to have the bad and and I
think Facebook is a great demonstration
of that on in certain Dimensions it's
marvelous in other dimensions it's it's
horrible
yeah I was watching the Senate meeting
with uh Gary Marcus and Sam Altman and a
lot of the senators were using the
Facebook
um sound bites when they were
interviewing Sam Altman and they didn't
realize that it's a completely different
business model that they're not trying
to
um maximize growth and engagement and
attention and
um it's it's not a social media company
in any way and similarly you're not a
social media company there's there's no
centralizing pressures if anything
you're trying to even though Facebook
say they're trying to do this you're
trying to genuinely maximize maximize
the individual's capability for
self-improvement and exploration
definitely yeah look Facebook
relies on people sharing you know
creating content of people sharing
things and then obviously relies on
people spending as much time as possible
engaging with the feed and to be able to
to show ads and uh when you've got when
you've got that kind of sort of
optimization going it makes sense that
you'd find some dynamics that are not
beneficial to individual users
and and the AI is radically different
than that what do you think are the
ethical risks of digitizing your mind in
general
um well there are certainly the
um
sort of obvious
privacy and uh and sort of security
risks of of digitizing mind uh not sure
I'd call those ethical those are sort of
just sort of practical uh risks
um
I think
you know we were talking earlier this
when you give humans
new capabilities to engage with each
other
Facebook is an example of that
um
it's hard to predict
you know sort of what what happens in in
those cases when you dramatically sort
of raise the resolution of humans being
able to understand themselves understand
other people discover other people like
them we didn't really touch upon that
but when things are digitized even
though today no one knows that other
people are digitizing their minds one of
the things
um that uh will allow them to do
sometime in the near future is
voluntarily saying no I would like to
sort of be part of this Corpus of users
that know that other users exist and be
able to connect with one another so in
the sense sort of dial in other people
like yourself were different than
yourself in these various Dimensions
there's obviously some privacy things
there that will need to be considered
and pseudonymity and things like that
that sort of make people feel
comfortable in being able to do that and
and and sort of uh
you know not not disclose personal
information about themselves that sort
of could get out of hand but this
ability to find other people like
yourself or different uh is is really
really powerful and uh when you start to
do that you might allow people to
discover their soul mates and discover
you know their future best friend or
discover their future co-conspirators in
the next insurrection
and and so I I think that there are
many potential
um
you know ethical challenges and and
learnings obviously that that will
happen as we all
walk bravely into this new world I mean
one of the um the angles I was thinking
about is I mean for example when we last
interviewed Noam Chomsky the recording
messed up so we had to deep fake him and
it was surprisingly simple to do and
even after Chomsky dies
um I could easily create an avatar of
Chomsky and I could use GPT to generate
a bunch of stuff like it we already did
cologne his voice I can clone his voice
again and then in some sense a virtual
mind can be seen as a form of
immortality you know to kind of preserve
yourself after you die but I guess the
ethical risk there would be well what
about preserving your legacy
are they are they sort of counter to one
another
I don't know because a lot of this is
about the diffusion of personal identity
in general so now it's infinitely
fractionated in space and time in the
physical substrate in the informational
substrate and something that's very
important to our well-being is being in
control of our narrative and our kind of
footprint of identity because the more
diffused it is the less control we have
over it
yeah so uh
I think digital immortality uh you know
recurs while for example is is one
that's been sort of working on on
wanting to to have this this kind of
capability sort of to capture uh your
own uh states of mind and and be able to
sort of either exist in the digital
realm beyond death or sort of less uh
provocative potentially sort of to to
leave this interactive artifact for
other people to be able to then sort of
engage and and and interact with you
um
I think the the
again I I hesitate to sort of predict
the implications of how that's gonna
impact
uh
you know what sort of would be seen as
sort of
uh
the Delta between Legacy before this or
after this
um and I I suspect it's gonna be sort of
a really sort of a personal you know
person by person
um
set of pros and cons that they will
discover in in those types of situations
um I uh can speak for myself that I'm
not looking for digital immortality
uh I I I think that uh death is as
positive a an event as is birth
and and the cycle goes round and round
but I think there are people whose lives
will be you know made
better
I mean they'll feel better about uh
death if they uh feel like they've been
able to sort of capture life in this
digital
um model and and uh exist beyond their
their years
yeah it reminds me of a thought
experiment by parfit
um he imagined a kind of teleportation
system where you could replicate
yourself and you know there you are on
Mars and you destroy the original and
it's all about this question of
um is there any difference if if your
mind can be recreated electronically and
their psychological continuity and
you're now on Mars then you've
effectively teleported yourself as long
as you destroy the original immediately
if you let the original diverge even for
a second then it may as well be a new
person and it has moral status and and
all the rest of it but yeah there is
there is this notion though of to what
extent is there a difference between the
human mind and and a perfect replica I
mean do you think it's exactly the same
uh no uh I again all of this is
obviously uh
philosophy and metaphysics and and
spirituality and like many things that
that Collide here
um my sort of personal uh
state of being I'll call it is
um I believe that that
Consciousness is not something that
human beings possess but the sort of
Consciousness is something that exists
and human beings Channel it
and uh we are expressions of
consciousness
and we have different names and
different hairstyles but at the end of
the day uh you know we are like radios
that are broadcasting radio signals and
and Consciousness is the radio signal in
each one of us as a radio and tuned into
different dimension of Consciousness
again all of these are words are crude
uh and and so in that kind of a model
then uh sort of a I'm an analog radio
and this Digital model is a digital
radio and just like I can get the signal
and articulate it Consciousness so
should a digital
um
model be able to do that as well and is
that the same Consciousness or different
consciousness
um depends on where you choose to draw
the lines
right uh and and an analog audio is
different than the digital audio because
digital audio is a lot more resolution
and uh you know on some dimensions and
on other dimensions you you know analog
has uh you know some depth that might be
compressed and in digital and so it was
like where do you draw the lines of like
which one is real and which one is is
not
yeah very interesting so a kind of
cosmic Consciousness that you tune into
but just to ask a clarifying question is
that like pan psychism where you you're
still a physicalist you still think it's
a property of the physical world it's
just certain Arrangements of physical
matter have more or less Consciousness
or do you think there's some other world
where Consciousness originates from
I think the physical world is a an
illusion
that Consciousness uh has
and
um
you know we look outside and we say we
see a tree but is it really a tree that
we see there or we've first of all we've
learned to recognize this pattern and
isolate it from the environment and say
this thing matters and somehow it's not
continuous with the physical world when
indeed it is all continuous in the
physical world the tree you know needs
uh soil and so it's a tree different
from soil or is a tree part of soil and
it all comes from the earth and and so
again I think as soon as you start to
get into the the world of of
being able to say that Consciousness is
separate from the physical world uh I'm
not sure that that's the uh
that's obviously a common sort of
Western thought approach is that humans
are made and and sort of show up in the
world somehow through either you know
Evolution or or Divine uh intervention
and and uh
and and we're sort of in this world and
the world is separate from us rather
than we are sort of part of the world
and there's a same part of the world as
a tree is part of the world there was
Iraq is part of the world we all come
out of this world sort of poke out of it
like fingers poke out of a glove
and is that a finger or is that the
glove fingering
I'm a big fan of a philosopher named
Alan Watts
oh yes yeah who was an Englishman uh and
uh you know Alan Watts uh I think is the
best sort of uh
articulator of my
sort of State of Mind metaphysics the
the there is just call it Consciousness
call it
the world call itself call it whatever
you want to call it and that's what
there is and we are all instances of it
not separate from it in any way shape or
form I'm as continuous with the tree as
I am with my hand
and it's only this isolation that our
our mind uh sort of projects in order
for us to be able to operate and speak
of things and and do things like that
yeah I I am I'm familiar with Alan Watts
I've not watched any of his videos in
many years but he's got a beautiful
voice and he's a great orator and I
think a lot of this um points to the the
self as an illusion and actually we
anthropomorphize absolutely everything
the way we think about everything the
way we conceive even of intelligence is
very anthropocentric so um yeah I'm
really interested in a lot of that but
you know final question on on philosophy
um do you think that as Minds become
digitized it could actually you know we
were talking about the digital divide
before with Facebook so now if you're in
the older generation I guess it's less
true now because a lot of old people do
use Facebook but if you're not on
Facebook you're not really you don't
exist anymore and there might be a new
form of digital inequality in a sense
where if you don't have access to these
virtual agents you you might not be able
to get a job
I I believe that this is
um
certainly going to be the case
uh I believe that as
you know
groups of people choose to sort of merge
with information technology and sort of
be able to leverage it
radically more effectively than people
who have not sort of merged with it and
who are still back to the example of
like typing in prompts into chat GPT
with their thumbs
versus that now they've got this data
set that sort of in in parallel able to
use all of these different dimensions of
these models or have an agent that
they've trained that can
um as their proxy at wire speed with you
know sort of parallel threads be be able
to orchestrate the digital world I don't
see how it's possible for
uh the people that choose not to do that
to be able to compete in the in the
world they might be able to live a a
good life and and and you know
potentially not use technology at all
even there are certainly people that do
that I have friends that still have
feature phones and and uh you know they
they take texts and and other than that
like that's the only sort of digital
that they use they stay away from it and
they they're proud of it and they think
that uh that they you know
in some ways are more human than we are
we're sort of like cyborgs that have
already plugged into you know this
generation of Technology now we're about
to go way way beyond that
um
but at the same time like those people
couldn't possibly compete in the modern
sort of world of whatever business let's
say uh if uh if they're not able to to
leverage these tools so I think we are
about to experience sort of a much
greater potential inequality but at the
same time I guess the thing that we're
proposing is
not all of us can learn to be software
developers something you can are willing
to dedicate the time have some aptitude
whatever it is right
but let's say that you know for crudely
speaking not all of us can learn to be
software developers or prompt Engineers
or whatever
um but you know if our approach is Right
which is all we have to do is to be open
with our AI to engage and digitize our
mind we don't have to be
the we do the things that are human
which is be able to communicate with us
with you know an entity and then it can
do all of that sort of work for us and
not become sort of an equalizer because
everyone has access
to that
yeah I can see it both ways it's very
plausible that it could be an equalizer
and I also see how it might not be some
of the critics of transhumanism in
particular they talk about this
potential um kind of fractionation and
Divergence of different elements of
society and it sounds like science
fiction when you talk about people
plugging in neural implants and stuff
like that but when you think about this
re-antologization and the way that
fluoridi talks about you know in terms
of a digital divide and needing to use
technology and and
um increasingly technology on top of
Technology on top of Technology if you
imagine you know like if a child grows
up in the forest and doesn't acquire
language then they're almost like an
animal they can't survive in modern
society and similarly if you took
someone from the 1930s and placed them
into today's world of language models
and virtual reality
um it would be like a fish out of water
all over again so I can kind of see the
potential for things to either become
more of unequal or potentially be
democratized I don't really know
yeah I think I think depends on what's
required of the human uh sort of time
mental capacity and and uh you know what
are various other sort of Dimensions uh
to be able to do that humans are quite
diverse in in their abilities to you
know pattern match uh
Rock Concepts learn
Etc so today we have a lot of inequality
when it comes to that uh but if if we
can sort of Outsource uh a lot of that
to uh technology and we human simply
again
exist and allow the technology to find
our weaknesses and sort of augment them
become a digital prosthetic
for those of us that could use a digital
prosthetic and for others who don't need
a prosthetic for the technology to
discover our deficiencies and then be
able to create the learnings we need in
order to be able to level up
I guess I I would fall on on the side of
optimism that this can
help us dramatically in in sort of
equalizing the world rather than what we
have today
yeah I I agree with you yeah I think the
crit the the critics say that we
shouldn't think of deficiencies as being
deficiencies we should think of the as
being part of the human condition but
it's it's a fascinating um uh
philosophical thing just in in closing
so this is this is really really cool so
you guys are building this startup and
we are going to do a Discord Community
hangout um on the mlsd Discord where
folks can get involved and ask a bunch
of questions because um Dimitri you're
trying to get a whole bunch of people in
the community together to think about
how to develop these prompt templates
and and where you're going to go with
the product so can you talk to that a
little bit yeah look we are
um we're a small team
that have built sort of the
infrastructure to allow humans to show
up and play around with all of these
ideas that we've been speaking about and
and so they can go to our website uai.ai
uh y o u a i dot a I sign up for a free
account join our Discord and
um what you can do now is you can one
start digitizing your mind and as you
started to do and sort of play around
with some of these prompts
there's about 1500 prompts in the system
now soon there'll be many more again all
those prompts today are created by uh
humans primarily they've been created by
our team but we are opening up the
platform to allow any user to create
sort of a la carte prompts or more
importantly to create these collections
of prompts in whatever area they'd like
to enumerate
um you know collection of signal before
and so if you're interested in whatever
travel you can come in and create
collections of prompts that have to do
with teasing out of human minds and
disambiguating and sort of depending on
what level of detail you want to
disambiguate to
creating these collections for for
people to to engage with
um and uh and of course the the other
thing you get for that is you the people
that engage with those collections sort
of tease out the signal that can then be
used to contextualize conversations with
chat gbt and soon Claude
uh and and as we move forward
um you know we're expecting that the
community will be instrumental
in Discovery sort of in research uh
about this because we are all human and
we all have the mind and all of our
minds are different
and we think this diversity of of you
know different humans sort of
uh
creating you know the system itself you
know which really just prompts in a
sense uh is going to be key again
eventually all of this is gonna be a
data set that can be used to train a
model that will do auto prompting and
um
and and so over time I I think uh a lot
of it if not all of it is going to be
driven by by the machine prompting
rather than humans prompting but today
it's all humans that are that are doing
the work and and the research in a sense
yeah and I guess all the more reason to
have an open-ended diverse process
because we need as much entropy as
possible
um we need many many different people
you know with different backgrounds
contributing to this process so that's
absolutely brilliant so please um do get
involved in Netflix I'll be publishing
it on the mlst Discord after this goes
out and probably in the next week or so
we'll we'll do that Meetup session
together and um yeah just uh finally
Dimitri what what's what's on the road
map for you over the next few months
um so
uh as we're recording this we have not
yet launched these two applications that
I mentioned earlier uh I think one is
going to be called context this is to
fill out the prompts and talk to large
language models uh second one is going
to be called insights same thing humans
can create these collections of prompts
other humans can answer them and you
know we will Implement some insights
that can and again those will evolve
over time initially you know they might
be quite crude but you'll be able to
sort of uh look at groups of people and
and see where there might be you know
sort of anomalies and where there's
alignment where there's misalignment uh
beyond that
I'm guessing about a month uh from now
we will be launching a people matching
application that will allow you to
choose to Overlay your mental model uh
with another person and then and
eventually potentially multiple people
uh and sort of choose the level of
privacy of that you sort of want to How
Deeply you want them to to instantly see
and and compare themselves to you
um
yeah those are really the things that
that are in the near term and and again
as we sort of move forward uh you know
we go down that path to sort of an
intelligent personal assistant but to us
that sort of comes later right now it's
it's sort of about being able to
um
understand yourself understand other
people and leverage all of this
understanding to drive
um you know productivity and sort of
capabilities in dealing with uh with a
my AI models of today
fabulous well so that that was a call to
action folks please get involved in our
community session so we can help Dimitri
um you know test and build out the next
iterations of of his products but
Dimitri it's been an absolute honor
thank you so much for joining us today
really appreciate it my pleasure thanks
so much